matthew wow i did have a little bit of
crush on uh
the young lady sitting to the left of me
from man of the moon christ
one of my early early crushes and if
you've seen the movie you see i mean
inevitable i mean what's not to have a
crush on yes sounds like matthew
mcconaughey had a serious case of puppy
love while appearing on the ellen
degeneres show the actor admits to rhys
she was his first celebrity crush what
oh are you just learning this yeah yep
matthew says it developed after seeing
her star in 1991's the man in the moon
marie
what's it like to kiss a boy
depends on the boy that was your first
celebrity
crush early early crushes and if you've
seen the movie you see i mean inevitable
i mean what's not to have a crush on
look at yes
oh you're so sweet that's true reese
also reveals her first crush and sadly
no it's not matthew oh my first
celebrity crush was probably
jim morrison from the doors
how old were you
13. i was a weird kid
the trip down memory lane was fun but
for now the two stars are preparing for
the release of their animated musical
comedy sing two clay callaway is a
recluse no one's seen it for 15 years
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running i won't let you down
sir better not or i'll throw you off the
roof
when e.t caught up with matthew who
plays the lovable koala buster moon he
shares why he's passionate about making
animated films making some content and a
film that my kids can go watch that
families can go watch putting some good
news out there in a world right now
where it's been a lot of frustrating
news uh putting a story out there that
is hopeful it's full of joy that says
hey keep dreaming keep hustling to make
your dreams come true we could use we
could use that belief in the fairy tale
coming true again right now speaking of
family for reese and her fellow sing to
co-star scarlett johansson they tell e.t
their kids are no strangers to hearing
their moms hit those high notes at home
i do this dumb thing where i'm on the
treadmill and i sing like parts of songs
because i have my earphones really loud
so i'm like
everybody makes fun of me
it's like you're such a dork and like if
you're gonna sing just sing the whole
song and i sing a lot uh all the time
i'm always saying a lot i sing a lot at
work i sing all the time my daughter
it's really funny because
i sing a lot of songs like when i was
growing up i watched a lot of rogers and
hammerstein musicals and so i sing a lot
of these songs that are like from the
40s and 50s and whatever and then but my
daughter also now sings them just
because i sing them a lot but like she
she doesn't the lyrics are all kind of
weird and it's just it's just absolutely
hilarious like just to hear her singing
what she thinks you know is something
from i don't know it could be like
oklahoma or whatever and yeah she's
it's a pretty great
you